[Music]
hello everyone as a follow-up to the
video i posted about how i like to
improvise and compose excerpts to help
me practice difficult passages i'm going
to respond to some of your comments and
give you ideas for the passages you
asked about so let's get started
luckily i've played this before
[Music]
i can't play it anymore
good
now i can really talk about it in this
passage i'm looking for the pitches that
form the outline of this phrase that
should be brought out
[Music]
as i divide the passage into sections
i'm isolating certain bits that are
difficult for me and that i need to
repeat a bunch of times and i'm padding
it with some of my own musical ideas
[Music]
and i see it in two sections
plus
[Music]
so
[Music]
this next passage involves some grace
notes and i would pay attention to the
wrist and how you're relaxing it
beforehand and i would also view the
grace notes as part of a blocked chord
that's broken up instead of trying to
view it as individual grace notes that
are leading into a downbeat
[Music]
so right before
the grace note i would make sure my
wrist is nice and loose
[Music]
right here
and i would add in just a tiny tiny gap
between the d and the start of the grace
note
[Music]
in practicing this i might
just block
these three notes
[Music]
so just by playing this over another
chord instead of a minor
going to g minor
and then going back and forth it could
be a nice way to practice
nice
the next passage deals with arpeggios
specifically a very fast and loud
descending run
[Music]
so if you're talking about the very last
arpeggio i wouldn't use five
i'm gonna assume maybe it's the one
before
[Music]
yeah it's probably this one
okay
so this one is made up of
these five notes
repeat it down
one octave
[Music]
yes
here are some ideas to work on the
shifts and hand position where your
fifth finger is going over the thumb so
i would practice this slightly under
tempo
stopping at the fifth finger
[Music]
and i'll do it a couple of times in each
register because
your hand will feel different when
you're playing it up here
and versus when you're playing here
[Music]
even though they're the same
notes
so do that
[Music]
i would make sure that
relatively speaking my wrist is in the
same position
going from here to here
i wouldn't
try to move my elbow this way
to help me
reach over
i just want this movement to be
lightning fast
so this might be good to repeat
so what i'm doing here is i'm isolating
that
transition point
three two one
five four three
i'm just going to repeat it in this
octave
this register
and
one lower
and with that i'm going to add
an f major chord
and then a g major chord below
[Music]
i'll just repeat that
also i would make sure to do this in a
slightly elevated volume so that you're
matching what
is required for this run
[Music]
so i have a few more from the session
that i'll post in the next how can i
practice this video and to close off i'd
like to share a short piece written by a
subscriber after i posted my 100 notes
challenge
so long story short after gathering a
bunch of pieces written by you all which
by the way thank you so much for
participating in that i tried a couple
different video ideas everything from
adding my own graphics adding some sort
of drawing to them
trying to splice them up in a sort of
way and combining them adding some sort
of commentary
but none of them felt right and i think
it's because they're just complete on
their own so what i decided to do is to
include some of them at the ends of
certain practice notes videos so look
out for them in the future
[Music]
let me know which passages you'd like me
to cover next and please be as specific
as possible in terms of which measures
you're talking about and what you're
having trouble with
anyway thank you so much for watching
please subscribe if you haven't already
and i'll see you in the next video bye